اكثروا من تسعه اشهر مره من عمر الحرب في
اوكرانيا استنزفت مخزونه الاسلحه لدى
الجانبين ليتواصل البحث عن امدادات وبدات
معهد الابحاث البريطاني رويال يونايتد
سيرفس قال ان ذروه القتال في دمباز شهدت
استخدام روسيا ذخيره خلال يومين اكثر مما
لدى الجيش البريطاني باكمله وفي ظل عدم
وجود اعلان رسمي من الجانب الروسي تقدر
المخابرات الاوكرانيه ان الروس استخدموا
بالفعل
80% من صواريخ اسكندر البالستيه قصيره
المدال استهداف المدن الاوكرانيه والبنيه
التحتيه للطاقه اما المخابرات البريطانيه
فقد اشارت الى ان روسيا ربما استنفدت
مخزونها الحليب من المسيارات الايرانيه
الانتحاريه وانها تنتظر المزيد من الشحنه
الان وما تعثر الاقتصاد الروسي بسبب
العقوبات الغربيه تحولت روسيا الى ايران
للح قولي على الطائرات المسيره والى كوريا
الشماليه للحصول على قذائف المدفعيه
والصواريخ هذا عن روسيا على جانب الاخر
تكافح اوكرانيا للحفاظ على تدفق المعونه
الغربيه من قذائف المدفعيه والصواريخ
المضاده للطائرات والدبابات وصواريخ مارس
وانظمه الاسلحه الحيويه الاخرى
استمرار الحرب لا يشكل عبءا فقط على
الدولتين بل يشكل ايضا ضغطا على الصناعات
الدفاعيه في الدول الغربيه حسب ما قال
نائب وزير الدفاع الامريكي لشؤون السياسات
اشار المسؤول الامريكي الى ان الدول
الاعضاء في الناتو قدمت 40 مليار دولار من
المساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا وهو ما
يعادل تقريبا ميزانيه الدفاع السنويه
لفرنسا في الوقت نفسه ينقص مخزون الاسلحه
لدىك صحيفه واشنطن بوست قالت ان جميع دول
الناتو قلست قدراتها الصناعيه الدفاعيه
بعد نهايه الحرب البارده فمثلا في
الولايات المتحده انخفض عدد شركات الدفاع
الرئيسيه من احدى و50 الى 5 كما ان شركات
الاسلحه هذه ركزت على انتاج عدد صغير من
انظمه الاسلحه عاليه التقنيه التي كانت
مثاليه لخوض حرب ضد المجموعات المسلحه
لكنها غير كافيه عشان اني صراع طويل الامل
ضد قوه عسكريه تقليديه مثل الصين او روسيا
[موسيقى]
واشنط الى ان اوكرانيا بحاجه لدعم لدعم
كبير لكن بعد العوائق تقف امامها القدره
الانتاجيه والوقت عاملانه يعقلان نسبيا
تسليم الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا لاسندها في
مواجهه روسيا الصحيفه الامريكيه اعتبرت ان
افضل هل هو مساعده اوكرانيا على كسب الحرب
بشكل اسرع من خلال التزويدها باسلحه
متطوره مثل مقاتلات اف 16 والصواريخ
التكتيكيه طويله الاماد اتاتمس وغيرها لكن
الولايات المتحده رغم المساعدات الكبيره
التي قدمتها لاوكرانيا الا انها رفضت مثلا
ارسال صواريخ بعيده المدى قادره على ضرب
روسيا لذلك تسعى واشنطن لارسال صواريخ
اقصر اقصر في المدام مثل بطاريات صواريخ
ناس ناس اوكرانيا ايضا لديها بالفعل
بطاريهتان من هذه المنظومه ومنح البنتاجون
شركه راديون عقدا لصنع سته بطاريات اضافيه
وتسليمها لاوكرانيا ايضا من البدائل
المتوفره بطاريه صواريخ هيمارس واسلحه
محموله من نوعيه جافل وايضا ستنجر بحسب
واشنطن بول جميع البدائل ستكفي لي فتره
مؤقته فقط ولن تدفع الدول الغربيه لاعاده
تعبئه الصناعات الدفاعيه خاصه وان توسيع
خطوط الانتاج لن يحدث الا ان وجدنا انفسنا
في حرب عالميه ثالثه
[موسيقى]
رغم التقرير الغربيه عن استيراد روسيا
للصواريخ من دول خليفه
كشف ان روسيا مازالت قادره على صناعه
الصواريخ محليا
محققوا الاسلحه في اكياس وجدوا ان بقايا
صاروخ كروز روسي واحد على الاقل من طراز
وواحد تم استخدامه في هجمات واسعه النطاق
على العاصمه العاصمه الاكرانيه كيف تم
تصنيعه في اكتوبر وبعد اشهر من العقوبات
الغربيه الهادفه لحرمان موسكو من المكونات
اللازمه لصناعه تلك الذخائر تم تصنيع بعض
صواريخ متوسطه خلال الشهرين او الثلاثه
الماضيه
نقلت عن خبير اسلحه قوله وان استمرار
روسيا في صنعاء صواريخ موجهه متقدمه يشير
الى انها وجدت طرقا للحصول على اشباه
الموصلات وغيرها من المعدات في العقوبات
خاصه وان مخزنات موسكو من هذه المواد لم
تكن كبيره قبل بدء الحرب اصلا مجموعه
ابحاث بريطانيه فحصت بقايا الصواريخ
الروسيه التي وجدت ووجدت ان معظم المعدات
العسكريه الروسيه المتقدمه التي فحصوها
مثل اجهزه الراديو المشفره واجهزه تحديد
المدى بالليزر تمت صناعتها باستخدام اشباه
الموصلات الغربيه ومع التصنيع المحلي يشير
تقرير المجموعه الا ان الحكومه الروسيه
امره الموظفين في مصانع الذخيره بالعمل
للساعات اضافيه لانتاج المزيد من الذخائر
في وقت باتت فيه روسيا تطلق الان عددا اقل
من الاسلحه بعيده المدى على اهداف
اوكرانيه وبينما يترقب العالم حرب الشتاء
قد يقف هذا الفصل في احد جوانب الحرب في
صفي اوكرانيا بحسب وزاره الدفاع في
افريقيا مسؤولون عسكريون قالوا ان
المسيرات الانتحاريه ايرانيه غير مصممه
ولا تصلح لبرد الشتاء خاصه وانها مصنوعه
من البلاستيك ومواد اخرى غير مقاومه
لتسقيع روسيا سبق لها ان استخدمت هذه
المسيارات لمساعده في الهجمات على البنيه
التحتيه الاوكرانيه وكانت فعاليه هذه
الطائرات موضه خلاف النائبه في البرلمان
الاوكراني ليسيا فازلينكو غردت على تويتر
امس قائله ان افضل ما في درجات الحراره
المنخفضه في اوكرانيا هو ان طائرات شاهد
لا تستطيع تحمل البرد يوم امس ايضا قالت
بس ان القوات الروسيه تستخدم بنجاح طائرات
بدون طيار تدعى تشون تقوم بمراقبه مواقع
القوات الاوكرانيه متحدث روسي اضاف
للوكاله لان المسيره مجهزه بمعدات تصوير
حراري ورؤيه ليليه الاهم انها تعمل في
درجات حراره هروح بين 40 درجه مئويه وكحد
اقصى 30 درجه مئويه
تحت وربما يفسر كل هذا ان هذه الطائرات لم
تظهر منذ السابع عشر من نوفمبر الماضي